okay when the media haven't been
freaking out about separating kids from
their families and going into the
shelter's and calling them concentration
camps over the weekend they were
freaking out about what they thought was
going to be another Oh nail in the
coffin of Donald Trump another instance
of Russian collusion whoops
except it wasn't but let's watch just
you know more questions about
potentially another Russian having
meetings certainly with someone that's
associated with the campaign
specifically in this case Roger stone
and Donald Trump being so close for so
long
raises additional questions about what
the president the now president then
candidate may have known about these
Russian contacts this is my ninth
presidential campaign and there I
there's never been anything like this
the level of contact between one
campaign and one foreign national that
goes over and over again okay or
laughing here in the studio joining us
to explain is the man himself Roger
stone Roger I had to treat you with that
montage because I'm watching it like not
one of them say the guy was an FBI
informant not one of them tell us tell
it's really a story it's extraordinary
in May of 2016 Michael Caputo who
appeared earlier with Sean Hannity
contacted me because a man using the
name Henry Greenberg turns out to be a
paid FBI informant said he had
information that would be useful to the
Trump campaign he did not in fact
promised in the run-up to this meeting
dirt on Hillary Clinton as reported by
shell B Holaday of the Wall Street
Journal classic case of fake nose in any
event I reluctantly took this meeting
which lasted about 20 minutes it turns
out that Henry Greenberg is not his real
name that he is an FBI informant for
over 17 years was deported from the
country in 2000 has a ten-year prison
record for violent crime is associated
with Russian organized crime but more
importantly is in the country on a visa
sponsored by the Miami office of the FBI
because he is providing quote a public
benefit he's an
foreman at this very brief meeting mr.
Greenberg not his real name the FBI
informant first shows up wearing a mag
AHA and a trump t-shirt shows me his
phone of he and a Melman at various
Trump rallies and then lays it on me
that he has information damaging to
Hillary Clinton and he only wants two
million dollars for it
I reject his request for two million
dollars and he laughs and says it's not
your money I want it's Donald Trump
money and there it is giving up the game
this is an attempt to entrap me but to
compromise Donald Trump even Greenberg
or whatever his real name the Russian
FBI it was the Washington Post that I
reject is I yeah yeah but does he speak
like this Roger does he say I have very
good information on Hillary Clinton or
sound more like rocky or like Boris
badenov you sound more like Boris
badenov the real question here is not
why I didn't remember a meeting that has
no legal consequence because I got it
Roger I got to be really tough on you
because April 19th of last year you said
this let's watch I didn't talk to
anybody who was identifiably Russian
during the two-year run-up to this
campaign I'm not sure I did previously
either I very definitely can't think of
anybody who might have been a Russian
without my knowledge so that's what
everybody's hitting on today that's fine
but the question is not why I forgot a
meeting which is inconsequential in
which nothing improper or legal happens
the question is why does James commis
FBI run a known informant who's in the
country on a visa through the graces of
the Miami FBI office for public benefit
in on me he gave away the game when he
said I don't want your money
I want Trump's money this was an effort
to entrap Donald Trump Roger we need we
need the doctrine
on this though and I know you're gonna
be pursuing that because we need the
doctors mmm when if we want a Democrat
with asiel if you go to Democrat dossier
org
you can see his extensive criminal
background and all of the evidence that
he was an FBI in fine
I haven't on Intelligence Committee yeah
we got a role but thank you so much a
fantastic interview